please welcome the leader of the Labour
Party and our next prime minister Jeremy
Corbyn all together now jeremy corbyn's
a compliment and his message to members
and the nation during fractious
political times not least in his own
party
towering over a tall brexit an attempt
to rally the troops ahead of what they
expect to be an imminent constitutional
showdown if Parliament votes down a Tory
deal or the government fails to reach
any deal at all we would press for a
general election they're hungry for an
election not in their gift but hang on
what about the painstakingly agreed
referendum policy compromised ah
yes eventually for those listening
carefully failing that all options and
then perhaps the core surprise of the
speech what sounded like an offer to
back up the Prime Minister he's trying
to remove but let me also reach out to
the Prime Minister see I'll reach out to
everybody who's currently apparently
doing the negotiations if you deliver a
deal that includes a customs union and
no hard border in Ireland if you protect
jobs people's rights at work and
environmental and consumer standards
then we will support that sensible deal
a deal that will be backed by most of
businesses in the world and trade unions
but if you can't negotiate that deal
then you need to make way for a party
that can and will
a brexit helping hand from him to
tourism a really no this is a party
expecting an imminent threat [ __ ]
breakdown and they want to pin that
squarely on the government and the Prime
Minister as the korbinites assumed
control of his party from top to bottom
the radical economic policies pushed by
him and his Shadow Chancellor are now
Labour's mainstream from multi-billion
increases in childcare attacks on
bankrupt private finance initiatives and
attacks on some second homes for those
with two homes to help those without any
home mr. Corbyn arguing there is a new
majority in the nation the left wing
populism what's long being a scam is now
a crisis stretching as far as the X Tory
Treasury Minister Lord O'Neill who said
this week that much of this agenda
captures the mood of our time and let me
say to his lordship you're welcome come
and join us in the new political
mainstream if you wish the summer has
been a torrid time for mr. Corbyn on the
issue of anti-semitism here not quite
the requested apology as he asked to
draw a line I say this to all in the
Jewish community this party this
movement will always be implacable
campaigners against anti-semitism and
racism in all its forms
we are your ally but at the end of an
hour-long speech a rallying cry to
rebuild a divided country build up
Britain for that security together and
we can thank you conference
next if Frieza may put the deal we're
gonna be unsuccessful for economy merge
or super then scenario situation which
would be absolutely catastrophic for
business within this
it's a green operation position exactly
to set out what we should be
concentrating on is trying to force a
general election the problem with the
Prime Minister on this conservative
government is that they have lost the
respect and the authority of the rest of
Europe coordinated message if not
dancing for this party to keep options
open on brexit but after a tough few
months that's compromise buying a
confident Jeremy Corbyn some much-needed
party unity on almost everything else
tomorrow
he meets Michelle Barney Faisal Islam
Sky News in Liverpool